any words of encouragement for whether
it be you no future festival fine
founder excuse me or anyone building
something you know there's that what who
said that wonderful quote that I love
anything you build with passion invites
chaos and drama I think it's Francis
Ford Coppola that said that but on
getting through those growing pains in
those roadblocks because I'm sure a lot
of great things and ideas have been
abandoned because of that I think the
way to get through those things is to
set up your core principles early I know
that you know our mantra has always been
by filmmakers for filmmakers and it's
always been about the festival so any
time where we've been tempted to be
distracted by hey let's throw a huge
party here and we and there were years
we through massive parties with 3,000
people in Park City years that we went
to can and threw huge parties there a
lot of fun but at the end of the day we
always said wait a minute wait a minute
film festival like happy okay is this
helping the filmmakers it's not helping
the filmmakers and and we always kind of
come back to that you know is our little
you know intern internal battles is it
helping the filmmakers not helping as
long as we you always bring it back to
whatever the core principle is whatever
however you set it up I think that keeps
you on your path you know whatever the
path is and we've been we've been very
lucky to Peter Baxter who's really had
the reins of the festival for most of
the years has been very good at that
sort of always kind of you know putting
things into the perspective of okay is
this helpful for new filmmakers or isn't
so have a mission statement a mission
statement yes that's how subversive or
yeah exactly what exactly yeah yeah and
then stick to it you know don't don't
get don't get distracted and I mean
every year we literally revisit the
question Oh should we be in park city in
just something as basic as that ask the
same question every year and don't don't
make any assumptions from you were there
times that you were very close to
pulling the plug on it oh yeah yeah
we're yeah there have been times we've
been close to pulling the plug on
and I don't know about very close but
yeah definitely yeah right and just just
you just kept going back to the same
idea of why you started it in the
beginning exactly yeah and then amazing
how things change when you get a good
night's sleep and then you okay you know
what we'll go back to it yeah yeah I
know it always seems to no matter how
grim things have gotten we always manage
to head back there every year and how
what to do you know as long as we're not
like losing a lot of money doing it you
know that's okay
you